Apple's iPhone 16 Pro is going to be
better than you
think and in this video I'm going to
share the top 10 upgrades that we should
expect based on recent leaks and rumors
including some changes that only the
trained eye will detect which are
clearly visible Within These new
exclusive renders that we had created
for us and if you can't see anything
different don't worry I'm going to
explain them all in this video as well
as why they're going to be so important
starting off with the first upgrade we
just got a brand new leak from M quo
that has confirmed that the iPhone 16
Pro Models will be getting a massive
Ultra wide camera upgrade to receive a
new 48 megapixel camera sensor that
might sound like Overkill but I'd argue
that the ultrawide camera is where you
want the most amount of pixels possible
because the camera can basically see
twice as much as the main camera can the
48 megap camera will also help a ton for
dim and low light situations because
it'll use a techn technology called
pixel binning where it can act as a 12
megapixel camera essentially merging the
data from four pixels into one in order
to take in more light leading to better
looking photos with less noise now the
second upgrade is one of the differences
you can see within our new renders
specifically a brand new button on the
bottom right side of the pro model
iPhones I know it sounds crazy and it
doesn't make any sense but it's
apparently going to be called the
capture button and the main reason for
the weird placement is that it's
actually meant to be used when holding
your phone in landscape mode which now
strategically places that button in the
perfect spot for recording videos or
taking photos according to recent leaks
from Mark gurman it could literally be a
dedicated spatial video recording button
which makes sense because right now on
the iPhone 15 Pro Models you can
actually record spatial video but it
only works in landscape mode because
that's how the Vision Pro headset will
be viewing the videos moving on to
number three which is perhaps the
biggest noticeable change that we'll get
both the iPhone 16 Pro and 16 Pro Max
will get larger displays the 16 Pro will
be bumping up from 6.1 in to 6.3 and the
16 Pro Max will be going from 6.7 to 6.9
in the main reason for this is to allow
more internal space for new component
upgrades like the new 48 megapixel Ultra
wide camera sensor as well as larger
batteries including one big feature
update on the 16 Pro which I'll get into
in just a second the actual dimensions
of each model have leaked and it looks
like the width is barely going to
increase by only 0.85 mm on the 16 Pro
and 0.88 mm on the 16 Pro Max so it'll
still be generally as comfortable to
hold in your hand as the current ones
while making the display taller which
means you can fit more tweets or posts
on the screen but speaking of that new
feature that is coming thanks to the
size increase we have upgrade number
four some say the entire reason for
Apple to increase the size in the first
place is because they had trouble
fitting the new 5x Tetra prism telephoto
camera into the 15 Pro which is likely
why it came exclusively for the pro Max
model and let me tell you this new 5x
camera is my favorite new feature on the
15 Pro Max G giv you an entirely New
Perspective that you can't get anywhere
else thanks to the excellent lens
quality and stabilization well that
camera is now coming to the smaller 16
Pro and only because of the extra
internal space that will help it fit in
now moving on to number five it's
another change that you can see with a
trained eye by looking at our new
exclusive renders and that's actually
the action button Apple did a great job
in my opinion with this new action
button because the placement makes it
hard to press accidentally and the
software support is absolutely
incredible because there are no limits
to what you can do since it supports
custom shortcuts that can do basically
anything well with the 16 Pro apple is
actually going to make the button larger
to help make it easier to press and fill
in the extra space that we're going to
get with the taller phone size it's also
likely that Apple wants to differentiate
it from the regular iPhone 16 models
which will also finally be getting the
action button this year now for upgrade
number 6 we of course have the new a18
Pro chip which will come on the iPhone
16 Pro Models with the regular a18
coming on the regular models which is
great news because the regular iPhones
have been getting the previous year's
chips but not anymore this will be a big
deal because I ran a bunch of
calculations based on the info and leaks
that we have now and the regular a18
chip should outperform the A7 Pro in
both single core performance and
multicore which is is great news and as
for the A8 Pro it's going to be even
faster because I personally think it's
going to come with an extra 2 CPU cores
allowing it to finally outperform the M1
chip in multicore which is just crazy
and finally we have metal graphics
performance where the a18 pro should
perform almost as good as the M1 which
is honestly really impressive moving on
to upgrade number seven we have the
battery which will apparently get a full
redesign on the iPhone 16 Pro kutami on
X actually revealed a prototype battery
that looks completely Legit featuring a
new glossy metal shell which is exactly
what Apple switched to in the Apple
Watch series 7 which improved thermals
and actually increased capacity by 10%
due to the new tech so this is what
we're going to be getting in the new
iPhone 16 lineup which means that we
should get a noticeable battery life
Improvement especially thanks to
multiple other upgrades like the more
efficient a18 Pro chip for upgrade
number eight the iPhone 16 Pro will be
getting the latest Wi-Fi 7 spec which is
in my opinion a much bigger deal than
the Wi-Fi 6E that we got in the 15 Pro
mainly because Wi-Fi 7 is the first
version that allows you to connect
multiple bands at the same time for a
faster and more reliable connection so
let's say your router gives off a 2.4
GHz and a 6 GHz band the iPhone 16 Pro
would connect to both of them at the
same time which means you get a perfect
trans position as you move around your
house and even into your backyard
upgrade number nine is a very similar
upgrade but I'd say that it's even more
important according to leaks and rumors
the iPhone 16 Pro will come packing
qualcomm's new Snapdragon x75 modem
which is going to be faster and more
efficient leading to better overall
battery life since it uses 20% less
power and it actually takes up 25% less
circuit board space which will give
Apple more internal space for other
things it's also got 5G Advanced which
is the next step up and transition
before 6G comes down the road and
finally we have upgrade number 10 which
apparently has to do with Siri according
to M quo the iPhone 16 Pro will come
with a significantly upgraded microphone
with a better signal to noise ratio and
improved water resistance the main
reason for this is because iOS 18 will
apparently come with new generative AI
features exclusively for the iPhone 16
Pro Models so the upgraded microphones
will be an important upgrade so there
you guys go those were the top 10
upgrades coming to the new iPhone 16 pro
and pro Max models so hopefully you
enjoyed our brand new animated renders
and if you did subscribe above for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video
he